[Music]
hey welcome back to stylecraft we are
talking about
tone
today
and what you see in front of you right
here is my after effects project where i
created a style frame based around tone
so
everything in here is black and white
which is a lot of times the easiest way
to work with tone
before we add color in so we can come up
with really awesome amazing designs
in black and white only and that's
where we're only focused on the darks
and the grays and the light values and
it makes if you make a really powerful
design
with black and white gray values then
once you add color then it's even more
interesting to look at it's even a
cooler design
to look at so
we are going to design uh this style
frame but i'm going to do a little bit
different this time we're not going to
start from scratch i'm just going to
break down this project file and tell
you how i
created this
so
easiest way i think to do that is to
probably just start soloing some layers
here so this very first layer here is
just a very simple
star map
and it's just an image from
nasa or some telescope and it's just a
star map and what i did here is it
started like this it's just a blue
tinted image i applied a black and white
filter which made it black and white and
then i just applied some levels and very
subtle levels here i don't even know if
you guys can notice this in the
recording
but um if i turn it off
on off on just a little bit more
contrasty of an image is all i did by
just applying some levels
and you can see
the levels here i just adjusted the
blacks
off on
okay so that's the first part
very challenging i know but uh not
really so anyway so then i uh added a
mask
and this mask was set to add so that
we're only looking at this top part of
the image and the reason i did that is i
wanted to create more of a landscape
back here um and just have the star
field up here so um if i did turn this
mask off
you can see it's being shown through
here um which is kind of interesting in
itself too that's you know kind of a
different totally different look um but
i wanted to
create kind of like a landscape or maybe
this planet's kind of sitting there so
to do that i had to mask this background
off and
i'll show you why here in just a second
so the next thing is i added
a texture right this is all this is the
texture so if i reveal this
let's see here reveal in finder
and i pull this up you're going to see
all this is is just a texture i actually
love using this texture i use this
texture and quite a few of my designs i
can't remember if i've used it yet this
year with you guys
um but instead of some of the stuff i've
used on social media like instagram that
i've posted
i've used this texture so
for whatever reason i love this texture
and i come back to it all the time it's
just a very simple still image
[Music]
of this texture so
close that down
so all it is is it's brought into this
uh
this composition and you can see here um
it is set to a transformative screen
which is why i had to mask off the stars
in the background because the black
values disappear with screen so if i did
not mask those values out
you know that's how we saw
through the texture to the star
background so i masked out the stars
i've got the the texture here if i turn
everything back on again i have a mask
here on the texture layer
but
i kind of played around with that so
right now it's set to actually off and
that's what this image looks like if i
set it to
subtract which is what i played around
with
it makes the planet look a little bit
more
uh maybe ethereal and that the
the landscape um is a little more subtle
so i like this look a lot um i also like
this look this look looks a little bit
more like the planets resting
on this terrain like maybe they collided
or or something like that which i kind
of dug a little bit more um but like i
said i could set this back to subtract
and that's the look there so whenever
designing uh style frames it's always
fun to play around and just get totally
different looks just by very simple
things like here just using a mask right
so that's that part and then i've got
my
3d layer here which this is just a
cinema 4d file
with a simple mask on it as well and
you'll see here that this mask is set to
subtract as well
if i hit it to none you're going to see
the planet appear
right there very
very subtle
but it's just taking away a little bit
of the planet down here uh
to make it sit better and with this
terrain
here we're going to see it a little bit
better
none so there you go see the planet pops
on right there
if i go back to subtract there it is so
it blends in better
here with the uh with the landscape
none
subtract
so there's that so now let's jump in
to the uh cinema 4d file i'll show you
how i did that it's really simple so
here we are in the cinema 4d file
excuse me
and this is just a very simple scene
i've set it up to 1920 by 1080. it's 30
frames a second because this is a single
style frame a lot of times i work in 24
we've talked about
in the past but uh
24 frames per second or 30 frames per
second i'm sorry um
and this is really simple so if i
turn off the light here you can see
everything a lot better um there's just
a simple camera in the scene
just to get kind of the positioning i
wanted on the planets
um
there's a light which i'll turn back on
here in a minute but all this is is a
sphere which is my main planet set to a
radius of 100 centimeters
i've got another sphere which is my
front planet which i just brought you
know forward and z space right here
and i've got a back planet back here
that's just
set back in z space here
and then i've got a ring
and another ring right and these are
really simple too this is just the inner
radius is set to
a high value
compared to the outer radius so inner is
at 198 outer is 200
and that makes this really thin ring so
if i you know decrease this
this is kind of like the default
um of a tube which is what these are
but if i undo that
there we go and i've also turned up the
rotation segments to 144 because a lot
of times they default to like a lower
number like say 72
which you can't really notice so much
here
but if this radius was a lot
smaller
and i bring these down
let's say to 24 you can see it gets a
lot more jagged see there so that's what
the rotation
segments do so i'm going to undo this
and just to show you um if you're
confused you can see right here it's a
tube all i have to do is go up here to
create object
and where you at tube
tube
there's the default tube like i said i
brought the inner radius up
to
198 the outer radius was the default 200
and then i brought the height all the
way down like
so to like one
and then i increase the rotation
segments
and there is how we created it very
simple stuff so it's just
spheres one two three spheres and two
tubes right
that's all it is and then it's two
simple textures
and i'll tell you why here just a second
while there's two textures but all i did
for these textures is i just created a
i'll start over here i'll make a new
texture brand new texture just by double
clicking down here creates a texture i
turned off reflectance
and i
left color on and i just went into the
texture here
and i said
okay i just want to add some noise
and there's my noise and i just can
click and it opens up this noise texture
and all i played with was the global
scale so if you look right here global
scale is 100 if i go down
like let's just make it really a lot
smaller see how
fine that grain gets
if i make it back to 40 the grain's
gonna get
bigger see that that's all i did i took
it down to a grain scale of what is this
17 that's all i did
and then i just
drug it onto my sphere
and onto this sphere
this sphere and even the rings it's one
texture
right
but
i created a second texture
for this back planet
right here and i'll show you why so i'll
turn my light back on and you'll see my
light here is just an area light
that's all it is so to create an area
light we just go up here to light
area light
it starts in the center
and
[Music]
i just kind of moved it up
and i moved it out
and i moved it up and you can see here
right here in the watch if you watch
this planet here you can see what it's
doing
oh something like so
but
with the light here you can see how
bright this back planet is right and
inside of after effects
when i applied glows and things like
that this planet was really
really
bright in fact i'll just go back into
after cinema and i'll apply the original
texture that i applied to all these
spheres and rings i'll apply that back
to this planet back here
i'm going to save
and i'll go back in after effects and
watch how bright the planet gets right
here as it updates
see that it gets so bright and i it was
just it was too distracting to me it
should be much more subtle back there in
the background
so back in cinema i created a second
texture just for this planet
and the trick to making this just a
little bit darker
is very simple i just actually copied
the original texture so it has the noise
here and the color and then i turned on
diffusion it defaults to 100 i just
turned it right down to 50
and voila there's my darker planet back
here so if i save
and i go back into after effects
you'll see it get
dark again so that's all i wanted to do
if i wanted it even darker i could go
back into
a cinema here i could actually
darken it up maybe just maybe down to 35
save back into after effects
here it goes there i like that a little
bit better actually
so that's all that is
very simple three spheres one
two
three
and two tubes
that make up these rings and then two
textures one texture that's applied to
everything except for this guy
and this guy is just a duplicate of the
texture with the diffuse channel set to
50
super simple
and a light
if you have no lights
this is what your scene looks like very
blah and that's because cinema actually
always puts a
default hidden light in your scene so
that everything's lit up it's just so
you can see everything so if you're
working in cinema and you're working
with shapes you have to be able to see
them so there's a default light there
it actually turns off whenever you add
any type of light to your scene
so we'll go back into after effects
here we are it's going to update
slightly because my light there we go
so there is our
planet right
so what i did next is i wanted to add a
a ring layer a shape layer inside here
inside of after effects i could have
done this in cinema 4d but i decided to
go
into after effects to do this
so all this is is a shape layer right if
i turn off 3d
and i scale it back up you're going to
see this is just a very simple shape
layer
okay and it's got a mask on it which is
why it's kind of cut off there
let's undo that go back to 3d
and there we are
and um let me
so because i have this 3d layer here
um
i need it to interact with the scene
right so i needed a light and a camera
to make the scene interact otherwise
um if i was to just build this brand new
if i was to make a new shape layer
and i double clicked on the
the ellipse tool here
there's my shape layer
if i was to make this 3d without a
camera it's just there it doesn't know
where to go it doesn't know where to
where it should be in the scene
um but by adding a camera
it's going to know where to go now it's
disappeared right so let me turn off the
original shape layer here this shape
layer is is now gone
because
the default
zero out point for um after effects is
always 960 by 540 or if your comp is a
different size like 2048 it's always
half of whatever the width is and half
of the height right
halfway of 1920 by 1080 so 1920 half of
that is 960 which would be in here and
half of 1080 is 540 which is right here
well inside of cinema everything
defaults to zero zero right there's no
960 by 540. the center point of this
scene is always zero zero
so we have to center out our shape layer
to zero zero
right now you can see the center points
right in the center of our cinema
scene so that works
now how did i get this camera to be
lined up right well i talked about this
in the form lesson it's um i just
extracted a
camera from the scene
and it extracts a light and a camera so
it tries to match the camera from cinema
4d
and it tries to extract the light well
after effects doesn't use
uh area lights like after like cinema 4d
does
so it's just going to default to like
it's
a parallel light inside of after effects
which i can talk about here in a minute
but i know i'm jumping around a lot but
i'm just trying to explain things to you
guys
so we've got our camera here in after
effects it now reads the shape layer the
shape layer is way too big which is why
we can't really see it so if i just
scale it down you're going to see it's
coming into the scene
then all i did was i just went to the
rotation i said okay rotate on the x 90
degrees and there it is there's our our
ring
around our planet right
now this is not a perfect ring because
the ellipse
uh built it out at where's the size here
1920 by 1080 because that's where our
comp was so if i make it square i'd make
it 1080
by 1080 and there it is so now it still
looks a little bit weird because
it's going in front of the planet and
it's going in the back of the planet
right so that's weird so if i turn that
layer off go back to my original one
that's why i have a mask here
right i have a mask which is on a solid
layer
above here
so this is just a solid with three masks
on it mask 1
mass 2
and mask 3.
so i'm saying i want to see
this part and i want to see this part
and i want to see this part but i'm not
seeing back here and if i
turn this back off
that's why we can't see the ring behind
the planet here but we can see it in
front
on the side on the side right and i've
just set these to feather
10 pixels
all the way around just to kind of
make it look a little nicer i mean i
could go in here and i could really fine
tune
this edge
it's a little bit off maybe
um
but that's how we make the ring look
like it's actually going around and then
behind it
and then the shape layer is just if i
open it up you're gonna see here
it is
a stroke path
with a
dash
applied to it right i just added the
dash by clicking the plus button and
then i just played with the settings and
i i've decided that 42 was kind of a
setting i like because you can see here
it's moving it's getting further apart
so this is really big dashes which
that's kind of interesting in itself
um i could go the opposite way i could
go below 42 i could go
way down here
and it starts to fill in which is not
what i want but maybe
so there's really tight rings around it
so it's all a matter of just playing
around and finding what works for me
i decided i liked
this setting right here
so there's our ring
with our
alpha matte
set to the solid above it
right which is just our mask and the
reason i did this is because you can add
mass to shape layers but it gets very
kind of strange um whenever you apply a
mask to a shape layer that shape layer
wants to say oh this isn't a mask this
is actually a shape and i should draw
this
so i kind of stay away from adding mass
to shape layers because it does get
confusing i find it easier just to
create a solid make it an alpha or luma
mat and apply my mass to that solid
okay so what's next so next i when i
extracted from the cinema 4d file right
here when i hit extract it brings out
everything from the cinema 4d it can
bring out from that file it brought out
the camera and it brought the light
right so that's where this light came
from and boom there is the light now i'm
going to extract again and i'm going to
show you what i had to do to make this
look the way it does and i i use the
light because i wanted this ring
i wanted less focus on it on this
dashed ring shape layer we made here in
after effects so you know that's created
by using a light so without light with
light without light with light so just
gives a little bit more depth to the
image right a little bit more uh tone as
well because we're going from bright
values here to dark values over and here
so if i turn this one off and i go back
to my cinema 4d file and i just say
extract
it's creating a second camera which i
don't need
extra light
all that jazz so there is my light
right and i can't see my shape layer
because the light
is way up in here
um that's where the light wasn't 4d it
thanks and
it's using a parallel light which i am
not a fan of parallel lights
so if i go to light options i can see
right here it's set to parallel i just
changed it we'll if i change it to point
immediately you're going to see
boom there it is right and that's
creating some tone because it's brighter
here and it's darker over here
but i found that um i could
play with the spotlight and make it look
even more interesting
um i think i did turn the intensity down
as well
yeah i turned it down to 150
with just this is just you know a matter
of playing around with the lights as
well um but we could do the trick where
we look through the light that i showed
you guys in a previous lesson um or i
could just go to two views here this is
a custom view
and i say okay where's my shape there's
my shape layer right there and see my
light
right here my my light's actually
pointing back it's up above the shape
layer it's just pointing straight back
which is why i can't see anything
over here so the first thing i would do
is i'd probably play with my um
oh probably my rotation let's see
yeah make it kind of point down
and you can see right here i'm starting
to see it right here and over here i'm
seeing it as well
maybe i'll
that's my y rotation yeah more of it's
coming in for sure at this point
maybe more
x
yeah so there you go so we're seeing
definitely more seeing more of it here
the z is not going to do anything this
is just rotating it
like so
um i could also play with my point of
interest maybe
see what that does
yeah not doing too much there so back to
my rotation i'm just going to play with
this until i find something i kind of
like kind of
matches what i want to do here
yeah so that's a little bit darker than
my original
right there but that's pretty
interesting as well i do like that
um so that's how you come up with uh
giving the the shape layers or even any
other 2d layers or two and a half two
layers that are in after effects if i
had some typography in here or something
you know it's going to react to that
light
and it's going to make it uh darker or
brighter based on that light and it's
going to match it to the
light from from cinema 4d
so
um
let's see here let's go back in here so
now what we've got we've got the 3d in
here we've got the light we've got the
camera um we've got some we got the
background we added in already we've got
the terrain
that we added in so the next thing i'm
going to do is add a little bit of
atmosphere so it's starting to look
pretty interesting right just from some
very simple
a shape layer and very simple 3d and a
very simple texture which looks like a
terrain right
so the next thing i did is i added a
little bit of
smoke
behind the planet here
and all this is is this is from um
action vfx
um which the you know they've been
generous enough to give us uh some
footage for you guys to use so this is
prores 2k footage
that you guys can use for these projects
uh it's really cool stuff all this is if
i turn all these back off actually let
me not do that let me show you
reveal this in the project and then i'll
just bring it to its own composition
here
and you can see this is just smoke
that's blowing in from the side and then
kind of dissipates up and outwards right
it's all it is so what i did is i just
said i just kind of it started at zero
on the timeline
it started at zero which if i take it
back to zero it's gone right and i just
kind of pushed it forward in space and i
found that 59 i liked it you know about
59 frames into it
and all i did was i just moved it up
here so it starts down right here
that's the default position
and i just pulled it right up in here
and i liked the way it was looking right
there just i wanted to create a little
bit of atmosphere coming off of the
planet right i could also even duplicate
this now that i'm looking at it
and bring one in front of the planet
if i wanted to do that and just give a
little bit of atmosphere right here
and if i did that i would probably
just go ahead and mask it off
oh like so and then i'd feather it quite
a bit
and then i would get rid of this edge
here i just
maybe bring it up like that
so this is in front of the planet and
this is just behind so i do kind of like
that it's interesting uh the other thing
i did is i brought in another piece of
footage from action vfx which is this
ground fog
and this ground fog if i take it to its
own composition here it is at zero zero
really cool it's just some fog smoky
kind of stuff they shot on black that
just stays close to the ground
really cool stuff
i just brought it in here
brought to the top
and took it back about 169 frames
because i liked it right in there where
is that oh and i should also add that i
added a levels effect to it right
and this is without levels
this is width levels
all this is is i just adjusted the black
and the gray values right so if i reset
this there it is
you watch right here undo it it's just
bringing the blacks in
um same thing was done to the
smoke down here um i think i just barely
played with the gray values of it
yeah just to make it a little more
subtle because without levels there it
is with levels it's more subtle so you
can always bring in atmospheric effects
but it doesn't have to be like in your
face kind of effects you know they can
be much more subtle and effective that
way so
again the ground fog in the front
that's without levels this is width
levels very subtle atmosphere but it
brings a lot of
depth and um
interest to this design
because it is there and um
you know it helps with the tone because
it's white on black right so again it's
these white values that make us uh it
draws our eye our attention to that part
of the frame because it's a contrast of
black and white
values
okay so if i turn the stars back on
there they are they're back on let me
show you the fog ground fog is off
and on see how much uh depth it really
adds to this entire design
it makes all the difference right even
affects the 3d because it's above it and
it's set to a screen mode
um
so really cool stuff i've got another
solid layer up here which is
just a black solid
with a giant mass septus set to subtract
and all that is just to darken up the
foreground right here i just wanted a
little bit
less there we could have done this with
a vignette
effect but this is the same kind of
effect right here i'm just
and i actually want to bring this down a
little bit more i like a little bit more
of that
foreground
so that's pretty cool um and then i
think is the very last thing i just have
an effect layer going on which is right
here and if i change this to effects
you'll see that it sits below the ground
fog
and that's because i did not like the
way that it
affected the ground fog i made it too
bright
kind of threw everything off so i put it
down here
if i turn this guy on
there's our effect
and
seeing
yeah i don't like the foreground fog
that i added above the planet so i'm
going to turn that guy off
so on the effects
real simple what's going on here if i
start from the beginning so no effects
if i turn i started with grain and i
just picked a simple preset
in the grain
there it is i love to add grain to
everything it just
brings a different level of realism to
the image it's not so digital you can
really see it down in here
so with grain without
with without it also helps to blend
everything together then i add a glow
layer
which is here
and this is with without
with without
i added a second glow in the second glow
i turned the threshold uh down
so that it only really affected
up in here and a little bit here so with
without with without
so i added that and then as a final
effect i added glow noise and you can
see here i made it very vertical
versus
more of a
circle shape and this is just to give
this planet some extra noise like
there's something maybe radiating off of
it
so and this was just i played around
with the settings just a little bit
and
that was that so if i unsolo everything
it should look exactly the same and it
does and there is our
planetary system landscape um created
with tone okay so now that we've got our
tongue we use tone to design this in
black and white it's really easy to go
in now and add color and make our design
even that much more powerful that much
more interesting to look at so
just a real simple way to do that is to
use something like from video copilot
right andrew kramer the god of after
effects uh he's got this free plug-in
plug-in called color vibrance man i'm
just stuttering a lot today so if i
apply that boom it immediately applies
this kind of vibrant look to our entire
image
i could go and i could change it to
something like i don't know purple kind
of give it this retro 80s purple pink
vibe that's pretty cool i'm digging that
um but that's just an example of like an
overlay of color wash you could add you
know i could go in i could colorize just
the uh if i turn this off i could
colorize just this ring
i could do something like
you know it's a gray value i could make
it
oh let's just i love pink right now
so that's cool um you could go in you
could colorize a planet you could
colorize the terrain the the smoke
whatever you get the idea adding color
now is an extra
added layer of dimensionality extra
layer of cool factor to our design and
it makes it that much more interesting
to look at so
that's what i've got for you uh this
week on designing a style frame now i
think it's time for me to do a bonus
lesson for you and i want to do a bonus
lesson where i actually animate this
because i know a lot of you have asked
you know how do you go about animating
things and i've tried to show that over
the weeks but i think if i show you some
more it'll help you guys so let's move
on to the next lesson the bonus lesson
on animating the style frame